six weeks out from the Olympia you're on
the bathroom floor crying can you take
me through the story of that day I've
been prepping for weeks a lot going on
in my life something happened within my
family that was really stressful that
I'm not going to touch on but it greatly
impacting us going forward and causing a
lot of stress and anxiety myself and my
whole family and I had gotten the sign
of my health going wrong with this
inflammation in my shins I get edema I
started to get that a little bit I
didn't speak about anything it was just
like okay wake up do cardio you know go
to the gym I just don't think about it
my fiance she was noticing I was a
little bit off and she's like are you
good I'm like I'm good and then I was
like in the bathroom she came in like
are you okay like yeah she asked me one
more time she's like look at me are you
okay and I just started bawling all this
chaos going on in my life and I just
like I don't know if I can handle this
and she's just like yeah of course you
feel like that the world is on your
shoulders it's stressed out right now
and it should be this is of a lot of
opportunity in front of you and if you
want to quit you can but I know you and
I know you won't because you just need
to sit in this right let it know I'm
here with you but I know you're gonna
get out from this you're gonna go to the
gym you're gonna kill your work you're
gonna wake up and you're gonna keep
doing that and that's why like having
good people around you when you have
like a stressful life